BUCKS AND ALSO FOR PERSISTENCE.
GIANNIS, FROM THE TIME HE CAME
IN HOW MUCH HE'S IMPROVE SECOND
DOWN TRULY INSPIRATIONAL.
>> Mike: SATISFYING VICTORY FOR
THEIR COACH MIKE BUDENHOLZER WHO
WAS MIC'd UP.
WE'LL LISTEN TO SOME OF MIKE
BUDENHOLZER'S CELEBRATION
THOUGHTS.
>> WHOA!
WELCOME TO MILWAUKEE.
>> I NEED A COUPLE MORE, NOW.
>> YES.
>> CHAMPION, BABY.
GOOD WORK.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> SO PROUD OF YOU.
I LOVE YOU.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
>> WE DID IT COACH.
>> YES, WE DID IT TOGETHER.
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE BOTH COACHED.
YOU KNOW HOW TOUGH IT IS TO WIN
IN THIS LEAGUE AND HOW TOUGH IT
IS TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP, THE
FEELINGS MIKE BUDENHOLZER HAS
RIGHT NOW, THE FEELINGS OF
SATISFACTION AND PRIDE.
>> YOU COULD SEE WHEN HE CAME UP
TO TALK TO MALIKA, WELLING UP
WITH EMOTION.
HE'S BEEN PART OF CHAMPIONSHIP
TEAMS BEFORE IN SAN ANTONIO.
HE'S HAD CHAMPIONSHIPS WITH L.A.
AND MILWAUKEE.
BUT TO FINISH THE JOB UNDER SUCH
SCRUTINY WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
DOWN, AS YOU SAID, HAVING TO WIN
A GAME SEVEN ON THE ROAD AGAINST
THE NETS, HAVING TO OVERCOME
GIANNIS' INJURY IN THE FINALS,
AND DOWN 2-0 TO A GREAT PHOENIX
TEAM, HIS PRIDE, HE SHOULD BE
PROUD OF THE PHOENIX TEAM.
HE SHOULD TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN
THE JOB HE'S DONE.
>> Mike: MARK?
>> Mark: HE SHOULD TAKE A BOW.
THIS IS A GUY WHO'S JOB WAS ON
THE LINE.
IF HE LOST EARLIER IN THE
PLAYOFFS, HE WOULD HAVE LOST HIS
JOB.
THOSE WERE THE REPORTS AND THE
REPORTS WERE BELIEVABLE.
BUT HE TOLD TOGETHER, HELD THE
BASKETBALL TEAM, AND HE'S
CHAMPION AND DESERVES THE
CREDIT.
>> Mike: WHILE ONE TEAM
CELEBRATES THE OTHER TEAM A
CRUSHING DEFEAT.
THEY WERE UP 2-0, TRYING TO WIN
THEIR FIRST CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE
HISTORY OF THEIR FRANCHISE, BUT
THE SUNS COME UP SHORT.
AND THREE GAMES DOWN THE STRETCH
THAT WERE WINNABLE, BUT JUST
UNABLE TO MAKE A PLAY.
IT'S HARD TO TELL YOUR TEAM NOW,
I WOULD IMAGINE, MARK, THAT THIS
WAS A GREAT SEASON FOR THEM.
HADN'T BEEN IN THE PLAYOFFS FOR
TEN YEARS.
ONE OF THE WORST TEAMS IN THE
LEAGUE JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
SECOND WORST RECORD IN THE NBA.
BUT WHEN THEY LOOK BACK AT THIS
IT REALLY WAS A SPECIAL SEASON
FOR THEM.
>> Mark: IT'S TOUGH TO GET IT
TONIGHT.
YOU LOOK BACK DOWN THE ROAD AND
REALIZE HOW SPECIAL OF A SEASON
YOU HAD.
MONTY WILLIAMS, CHRIS PAUL,
DEVIN BOOKER, THE ENTIRE PHOENIX
SUNS ORGANIZATION, TAKE A BOW.
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE RIDE YOU
ALLOWED US TO JOIN YOU ON, AND
YOU HANDLED IT WITH CLASS AND
PROFESSIONALISM.
>> Mike: YOU HAVE PRIDE IN TERMS
OF MONTY WILLIAMS.
SPOKE ABOUT IT DURING THE
TELECAST AND WHAT KIND OF MAN
HE'S BECOME, THE KIND OF COACH
HE'S BECOME.
>> Jeff: HE'S A TERRIFIC COACH.
WAS IN NEW ORLEANS AND NOW IS
HERE AN EVEN BETTER LEADER OF
PEOPLE, AND I THINK IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
HEART ACHE LIKE LOSING IN THE
FINALS, HE IS THE EXACT TYPE OF
GUY TO BUILD HIS TEAM BACK UP
FOR WHEN THEY START UP AGAIN
HERE IN NOT HAVE LONG, IN A
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
MONTY WILLIAMS, THIS IS A VERY
GOOD TEAM AND THEY HAVE A GREAT
CORE OF PLAYERS AND THEY SHOULD
BE AT SOME POINT VERY, VERY
PROUD OF WHAT THEY'VE
ACCOMPLISHED.
>> Mike: MANY OF THOSE PLAYERS
PLAYING IN THEIR VERY FIRST
PLAYOFF RUN EVER -- THE BOOKERS,
BRIDGES, CAM JOHNSONS, BUT THEY
CERTAINLY DID SPECTACULARLY AS
THEY GET TO THE NBA FINALS FOR
JUST THE THIRD TIME IN NBA
HISTORY.
P.J. TUCKER ACQUIRED FROM
HOUSTON, MIDSEASON, WHAT AN
ACQUISITION THAT WAS.
AND LOOK AT THE JOY FROM P.J.
TUCKER.
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO, THE
FINALS MVP WITH